you know them as the guys who create
everything from household appliances to
jet engines General Electric but the
future of the innovation giant may lie
in something much less complicated air
this is the dual cool jet it's the
thinnest air mover in the world this is
the thinnest air mover in the world at
one millimeter thickness g e--'s
researchers have dubbed the dual cooled
jets or dcj the world's smallest air
conditioner and generating wind on a
small scale could translate to big
dollars the dcj because it's so simple
just two plates that move very gently
can fit in this application space is
much more efficiently think about it
fans are responsible for cooling down
most of the electronics you power up you
don't really need two computers to be
that much more powerful you really want
them to be thin we want to get this kind
of technology ready so it can go in any
consumer electronics products such as
tablets iPhones laptop products because
right now they're using fans to cool
down that's right our fans because they
are mechanical devices have limitations
and how can they can get the technology
behind the new air moving system was
originally designed by GE to improve
airflow through jet engines the dual
cool Jets essentially act as a miniature
pair of lungs they expand and suck in
hot air and then contract to expel cool
air so are we gonna see dual cool jets
in consumer electronics that's the plan
we're working on it so the GE game has
really want this for our industrial
products but at the same time if we can
help other companies use assistive
technology for their consumer
electronics we were very open to helping
them with that it's not just helping I
mean your licensing we're talking making
money here too we get this technology
out there in the world I think it has 53
hundred million dollar potential